if you want to stalk some great new
streaming content then you need to get
with today's video sponsor magellan tv
magellan tv is a new documentary
streaming service bounded by filmmakers
who love history their mission is to
tell the great stories that have defined
the human experience and with more than
3 000 excellent programs available on
magellan it's hard to stop once you stop
watching they've got everything from the
greeks to the great war plus modern
histories biographies scientific
profiles true crime and so much more and
their team adds more content every week
and what's one thing to love about paid
streaming services no ads just lots and
lots of content now i'm sure they've got
some great true crime content and for
you guys today i'd recommend checking
out the docu-series 10 steps to murder
on magellan it's 10 episodes featuring
some of the most infamous murders in the
world very murdery if you're looking for
less of a series and more of a movie
then why not check out the family inside
the manson cult also a good one right
now you guys can get a one month free
trial with magellan by clicking the link
in the description below it's content
for days and days so let magellan hook
you up you'll be glad you did and now
today's video
the freeway phantom is not among the
most notorious names in crime like the
zodiac or jack the ripper and yet he
managed to do the same thing they did
for a year and a half he terrorized
washington dc claiming at least six
victims and then even though he had over
a hundred police officers and fbi agents
on his tail he simply disappeared never
to be heard from again
[Music]
the murderous spree started on april
25th 1971 in washington dc this was just
one day after hundreds of thousands of
people gathered in the nation's capital
to protest the vietnam war chaos and
violence were the words of the day but
dc police would soon have another
problem on their hands possibly the
city's first ever serial killer who was
abducting and murdering young black
girls his first known victim was 13 year
old carol denise spinks on april 25th
she went out on a short walk to the
grocery store just four blocks away she
wasn't supposed to leave the house
because her mom was not at home but she
decided to risk it since her older
sister told carol that she could buy
herself a soda with the change as soon
as she walked out her mother spotted her
as she was returning home carol knew
that whooping awaited her back at the
house for disobeying so she decided she
might as well go get the groceries too
she was last seen by a neighborhood boy
shortly after leaving the store it was a
distance of just half a mile but it
seems like carol spinks disappeared
without a trace and without anyone ever
seeing her abductor her mother knew that
she should have returned in a few
minutes so she got worried once she
realized that her daughter was missing
she called the police and organized
neighborhood search later that night all
of this proved to be in vain as carol
spinks was never seen alive again her
body was found six days later dumped
behind a hospital on the embankment of
interstate 295
less than a mile away from where she had
disappeared she was still wearing the
clothes she had gone missing in gym
shorts a red sweater and brown socks
although she did not have her tennis
shoes on an autopsy indicated the carol
spinks had only been dead for two to
three days meaning that whoever
kidnapped her kept her alive for around
the same amount of time her stomach
still contained partially digested food
suggesting that he had also fed her her
body showed signs of sexual assault and
defensive wounds to her face neck and
hands and she was killed by
strangulation right off the bat we can
say that this investigation was tainted
by incompetent lack of resources and a
racial bias the two detectives who were
assigned to the murder of carol spinks
were roy lam and john moriarty they were
told from the start to make it snappy
since they were needed for street patrol
and to be on standby in case war
protests erupted into riots when lama
moriarty first started working on the
case the body of the young girl had not
been identified yet however it did not
take long for them to make the id based
on the location the clothes and the
physical description of carol springs
they canvassed the neighborhood and
talked to as many people as they could
but nobody remembered seeing anything
useful the only lead in the case came in
the form of some green fibers found on
carol spinks's clothes believed to have
come from the carpet of the car which
may have been used to transport her body
on july 14 it seemed like the killer had
already struck again when the body of 14
year old angela denise barnes was
discovered some things were similar and
some things were different the victim
was another young black girl and her
body had been dumped near a highway
again she had not been strangled however
but shot in the back of the head an
immediate connection was made between
this murder and that of carol spinks and
the rest to come and for a few years
angela barnes was considered to be one
of the phantom's victims in 1974 however
something unexpected happened police
announced that they had made two arrests
in the angela barnes case they were not
only confident that they had apprehended
the culprits but they also insisted that
this murder was not connected to the
other killings the killers were edward
sullivan and tommy simmons two former
rookie cops who used to work for the
patrol division of the metropolitan
police force the men did not make it
past their one-year probationary period
in 1921 and were forced to resign after
an incident involving missing revolvers
simmons claimed that his gun had been
stolen during a break-in but the weapon
was later found and matched to the
angela barnes murder he was arrested
first but police kept quiet on the
details to avoid warning sullivan that
they were looking for a second shooter
ultimately the murder of angela barnes
was ruled to be unrelated to the serial
killings but detectives didn't have to
wait long for the real freeway fandom to
strike again
[Music]
by the time the body of angela barnes
had been discovered the phantom had
already chosen his next victim she was
16 year old darlenia denise johnson who
lived in congress heights the same
neighborhood as carol spinks on the
morning of july the 8th 1971 she
disappeared while walking to her summer
job as a counselor for the oxen hill
recreation center it wasn't until 11
days later that a body was found it had
been dumped off interstate 295 again
landing just 15 feet away from where
carol spinks was discovered this was a
prime example of the police's lack of
interest in the case because dalini's
body had first been spotted and reported
to the authorities a whole week earlier
two people called the police on july the
12th and gave them the exact location a
unit went there and radioed a 10-8
message to dispatch meaning they didn't
find anything which would have only been
possible if they just drove by the area
and didn't even bother to get out and
look a week later one of the two callers
drove by the location again and saw that
the body was still there they told their
boss who was one of their friends who
was a police sergeant and he was the one
who finally found darlena when he went
to the area while he was off duty by
that point the long time spent in the
sweltering heat of mid-summer left the
body in an advanced state of
decomposition too advanced to tell
investigators anything useful at the
very least they could see that darlenia
johnson had also been strangled she was
also wearing the same clothes as she did
the day that she disappeared minus her
shoes given that the killing and
disposal methods were identical between
her and carol spinks it seems highly
likely that washington dc had a serial
killer on its hands but the metro police
were not ready yet to reach this
conclusion they worked the leads they
had they looked into the boyfriend as a
person of interest then they checked in
with the witness who claimed to have
seen darlenia in the company of an older
black man driving away in an older model
black sedan neither lead produced any
results despite the police's reluctance
to acknowledge the presence of a serial
killer in dc the freeway phantom had no
intention of stopping or slowing down
just eight days after the discovery of
darlenia johnson ten-year-old brenda
faye crockett disappeared in a similar
scenario to that of carol spinks on the
evening of july 27th brenda's mother
sent her to the nearby safeway to buy
some dog food she vanished on her way to
the store leaving behind no traces and
no witnesses a short while later her
family realized that something went
wrong and was out searching the
neighborhood for any signs of the
missing girl and that is when the case
took an unexpected turn brenda's younger
sister bertha stayed behind at home and
she received a phone call she answered
and she heard her sister's voice at the
other end of the line brenda was crying
but she stopped enough to say that a
white man picked her up that she was in
virginia and that she was coming home in
a cab that did not make a lot of sense
since virginia was over 170 miles away
and brenda had been missing for less
than three hours still a short while
later the phone rang again this time the
mother's boyfriend answered and spoke to
brenda although she mainly repeated what
she'd already said before this time
ending the call with a reassuring i'll
see you this gave the family hope that
brenda might return home safe and sound
but their hopes were crushed the very
next morning when the young girl's
lifeless body was found on u.s route 15
at the baltimore washington parkway in
prince george's county she had been
strangled and sexually assaulted
although this time the scarf that was
used to kill her was left tied around
her neck like before she was wearing her
own clothes but she didn't have any
shoes on and police found traces of
green fibers on her but unlike the
others it appears that brenda's body had
been washed clean prior to being dumped
in a very public area so that it would
be found quickly police speculated that
the differences in the modus operandi
could mean that the killer had some sort
of connection to the crockett family
since it happened so quickly after the
death of darlene johnson it was possible
that the abduction of brenda faye
crockett had been an impulse decision
one perhaps committed in the phantom's
own neighborhood that is why he acted
with a sense of urgency and he got rid
of her quickly while taking extra steps
to clean the body and what about the
phone calls were they a sign of the
phantom's increasing sadism as he wanted
to inflict more anguish on the family of
the victim this is possible although the
police thought the most likely scenario
was an attempt from the killer to
provide them with false information
further strengthening their hypothesis
that the murderer knew the crockett
family
after killing brenda faye crockett the
freeway phantom took a short break and
did not claim another victim until
october it was october the first
actually when twelve-year-old nenemosa
nino yates went missing her story was a
familiar one it was the evening and her
father had asked her to go to the nearby
safeway and pick up a few groceries
because he had to go to the hospital
where nano's stepmother had just had a
baby it seemed simple enough the safeway
was at the end of the street the young
girl made it there and bought all the
items but then her groceries were found
discarded on the street in front of the
store it looked like the phantom
abducted her soon after she left the
safeway once again without being noticed
by anyone one neighbor thought they saw
the girl get into a blue volkswagen but
this lead never went anywhere this time
the killer did not hold his victim
hostage unimogia yates his body was
found just two hours later by a
hitchhiker dumped off the shoulder of
pennsylvania avenue once again the
phantom had crossed state lines into
maryland but it remains unclear if he
did this out of convenience or if he did
it on purpose to complicate the
investigation all the signs of the other
murders were there the girl had been
sexually assaulted and strangled her
shoes were missing and there were green
fibers on her body it was at this point
that the authorities could no longer
deny the fact that they were dealing
with a serial killer when press for
answers by the press detective john
rossi said that there is some reason to
believe that there is some connection to
some similar deaths a few important
developments followed this admission for
starters the fbi was brought in even
though it too was pretty new when it
came to hunting down serial killers more
notably the newspapers decided to give
the murderer a name the washington daily
news came up with the freeway phantom
monika that was embraced not just by the
media
but by the killer himself his fifth
murder was the most brutal on november
15th 18 year old baltimore resident
brenda denise woodard left home in the
evening to attend a night class at
cardozo high school in dc she and a
friend got some dinner afterwards and
then took the bus home at one point
brenda got off the bus to catch a
transfer and that was the last time she
was ever seen alive her body was found
early the next morning by a patrol car
dumped off an access ramp onto route 202
near prince george's hospital brenda had
suffered the same fate as the other
victims but she had also been stabbed
multiple times was the excess violence a
sign of the killer's increasing sadism
or was it a necessity brenda woods was
the oldest of the phantom's victims and
her body was covered in defensive wounds
so perhaps her attacker stabbed her
because he could not easily subdue her
like the rest her shoes were also still
on her feet so at first police toyed
with the idea that this might be an
unrelated murder however then they
discovered the most unusual development
in the case inside brenda's coat pocket
the killer had left them a note which
read this is tantamount to my
insensitivity to people especially women
i will admit the others when you catch
me if you can freeway phantom this was
the biggest departure from his usual
ammo it showed that the killer was a fan
of the name the press had found for him
based on writing analysis handled by the
fbi investigators concluded that the
note had been written by brenda woodard
and dictator by the phantom they also
speculated that the victim knew the
killer and was somewhat relaxed in his
presence because the writing did not
show any significant signs of hesitation
nervousness or duress to some this was a
promising lead but others still believe
that brenda woodard might not have been
a victim of the freeway phantom and that
instead her true killer did everything
they could to incriminate him something
else unusual happened after brenda
woodard's death a freeway phantom
stopped months passed with no new
development so the fbi had to move on to
something else particularly since by
that point the watergate scandal had
erupted meanwhile the local police's
investigation had reached a dead end and
with no new leads it seemed like the
phantom had escaped their clutches then
on september 5th 1972 10 months after
his last murder the killer struck again
the victim was 17 year old diane denise
williams who disappeared while returning
home from her boyfriend's house her body
was found the following day by a trucker
in a similar place as the others a
grassy incline of interstate 295. she
showed the same signs of sexual assault
and strangulation as the other victims
her shoes had been removed but in this
case they were found discarded next to
the body
after diane williams murder the freeway
phantom disappeared once more
permanently this time as far as we know
these are the six killings generally
ascribed to him although some
investigators argue that another
teenager named tiarian bryant was also
killed by the same man the 18 year old
girl was found under a bridge on
november 26 1972. she is the only victim
whose body was not dumped near a freeway
so that might be why some don't think
that she was a victim of the phantom in
1974 when the watergate investigation
died down the fbi rejoined the hunt for
the killer with a renewed zeal over a
hundred investigators from five
different agencies formed a task force
to catch the freeway phantom a reward
was offered for any useful information a
tip line was set up which received
thousands of calls all leads were
pursued establishing a list numbering
hundreds of persons of interest all this
proved to be in vain as the freeway
phantom remains as elusive today as he
ever was when he began his killing spree
perhaps the most solid suspect one that
many investigators considered to be the
likely culprit was identified in 1977.
his name was robert elwood askins and he
worked as a computer technician for
elizabeth's hospital the same hospital
near the place where the first victim
was found although he appeared quite
genial at first askins had a dark past
having served time in a mental
institution and a prison for poisoning a
prostitute back in 1938. askins fit the
profile he was a middle-aged black man
who lived in the same area as some of
the girls and had a deep-seated hatred
for women that started when he
contracted a venereal disease from a
prostitute as a young man he ended up on
the police's radar in 1977 when he
kidnapped beat and raped a 24 year old
woman in his house before letting her go
but perhaps the most unexpected
connection was that askins loved to use
the word tantamount according to his
documents and his colleagues this was an
unusual word that had also been used in
the written messages left by the freeway
phantom inside brenda woodard's coat
investigators really liked askins for
the murders so they executed a search
warrant on his home he found a lot of
suspicious stuff women scarves pictures
of unknown women and girls even some
jewelry in the backseat of his car but
frustratingly nothing that could
positively connect him to any of the
victims they were perhaps hoping to
locate some of the missing shoes or
better yet something that matched the
green fibers found on the bodies but
alas they had no such luck one small
consolation was that robert askins was
found guilty of kidnapping and rape and
spent the rest of his life in prison so
if he was the phantom he did not obey
justice another popular hypothesis
claimed that the killer might have been
a member of a gang known as the green
vegas these men were responsible for
multiple abductions and rapes in dc and
maryland and garnered their name from
the green vega that they would cruise
around in looking for victims they were
eventually arrested and imprisoned and
behind bars one of them started talking
the inmate whose name was morris warren
claimed that one of the other members
was responsible for at least some of the
murders he provided the police with
information and even took them to the
areas where some of the victims were
dumped according to a 1975 memorandum by
d.c judge fred august who wrote on may
the 16th he took them to the areas where
brenda woodard a homicide victim had
allegedly been kidnapped raped and
murdered on may the 17th he showed them
the alleged locations dealing with
dalian johnson although while showing
them where her body was abandoned he
took them to the place where brenda
crockett's body was found both ms
johnson and ms crockett were victims of
the so-called freeway phantom homicides
this lead never panned out because
warren stopped cooperating he was only
ready to name names in exchange for
total immunity something prosecutors
were unwilling to give him but he also
got cold feet once word got out that a
prisoner was talking to the police
thanks to an overzealous politician who
divulged the information to the media
during election season ultimately
opinions are warren remained divided
obviously he became a suspect himself
but he appeared to have solid alibis for
some of the murders some of the stuff he
told investigators turned out to be
false so skeptics think that the rest
was just publicly available information
or clever guesswork others believe that
warren showed insider knowledge of the
crimes which suggested that he had to
have some kind of involvement and that
most likely the freeway phantom was one
or more members of the green vegas not a
lot of progress has been made in the
investigation in the decades that
followed modern forensics have been
unable to lend a helping hand due to the
poor management of evidence back in the
1970s since so many different agencies
were involved important evidence was
passed around from one place to another
a lot of files have been lost or
intentionally discarded and the few dna
samples that they have may become too
tainted to ever yield anything useful
the last time a dna test was attempted
in this case was 2009 and since no
results were made public we can safely
assume that it didn't go anywhere a
solution is not completely out of reach
but for the time being the identity of
the freeway phantom remains a mystery so
i really hope you found that video
interesting thanks again to magellantv
for sponsoring it also if you enjoyed
this content i've got a true crime
podcast called the casual criminalist we
cover stuff like this obviously but in
the podcast form i'll link to that as
well below and thank you for watching